-Henry Winkler. I want to talk about "Barry."
-What do you want to talk about? -This season.
-James Fallon, ladies and gentlemen.
-I want to talk about how good you are.
Can we talk about your career on TikTok?
-[ Gasps ] Well, you know, it started because my granddaughter
said, "Oh, Papa, you have to make a TikTok."
So we made a TikTok one Christmas.
Then the second Christmas, we made a TikTok.
And then I put the phone in the refrigerator because I thought
it was the coldest place in the house, in California.
And I, you know -- For a "happy new year."
Which is, like, you know, snowy and --
And so I opened the refrigerator.
You heard the chili and the ketchup clink.
And I just wished everybody a happy new year.
And then I made a TikTok with my newest granddaughter.
Our newest granddaughter, Francis Joan.
I sang her "The Apple Song" that I wrote.
-Yeah. How does "The Apple Song" --
-Do you want to hear it? -I would love to hear it.
Would you like to?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Maybe I should stand for it.
-Yeah.
-♪ Apples are red and apples are green ♪
♪ And some are yellow ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-That's my new favorite -- -Tariq!
-That's my new favorite song.
[ Laughter ]
You got a "Tariq!"
Not only are you a phenomenal actor and just a great person.
-Thank you!
-Gosh, I love your wife, Stacey, too.
So much, by the way. Really, I'm in love with her.
She is unbelievable. -Yeah. Live with her.
-You've written --
You've crushed the children's book game.
-And our newest one is coming out next year,
about a little duckling, a baby little duckling.
Lives on a pond in New Hampshire,
and she dreams about being a detective.
[ Laughter ]
Tariq! -Hey! You have -- Now --
But now you're writing --
Henry, you're writing your memoir.
-But you know what? I am so nervous about it.
I don't know what to write.
I thought maybe there would be a chapter of --
someone would yell out a celebrity,
you know, like, "Kareem Abdul-Jabbar!"
Oh, so, I was in the locker room in the '80s.
He threw me his jersey after a game, and I didn't know --
I didn't know he was giving it to me,
so I threw it in the hamper.
-What?! You could have had his jersey?
-I could have had the jersey.
I put it in the laundry.
-This is real? -So real.
-If I name a name, could you have a story?
-Go ahead. Give me a name.
-Lady Gaga. -Lady Gaga!
Okay, so, at NBC, I'm at a party.
She's sitting there at the table.
I love this woman. Great, talented.
And I walk up to her, and, of course,
I trip over my own foot, and I fall in front of her.
"Hi."
[ Laughter ]
And then I just kind of slinked out of the restaurant.
-Yeah. Cher. -Cher.
Cher called me once and invited me --
-This is amazing. -No, truly.
-These are real stories? -Real stories.
She invited me -- She used to have great
skating parties in L.A.
-Okay. -So, she called me up
and she said, "Can I talk to Henry?"
I said, "Hi. This is Henry."
She said, "You don't sound like Henry."
I said, "No, no, no, it is Henry."
She thought I was the Fonz. -Of course.
We all thought you were the Fonz.
-You did? -Well, you are the Fonz.
-[As the Fonz] Alright. Then don't look me in the eye.
-[ Laughs ] Wow! Yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey! -That's it right there.
That's exactly right!
So, Cher calls you and says...
[as Cher] "You don't sound like..."
-Yes. She sounded like that.
-"You don't sound like Henry." -That's true.
♪ You don't sound like you are the Fonz ♪
-[Normal voice] She said that? -She said that.
I could not imitate her the way you did.
-[ Laughs ] I probably couldn't.
And did you go to the roller-skating party?
-I did not because I was embarrassed.
-Really? -Yes. Because I'm not a skater.
-And the Fonz wasn't a roller skater, was he?
-No, he wasn't.
There was one episode where I had to go with Potsy,
to do anything he wanted 'cause he did me a favor.
-Yeah. -And he took me skating.
And, you know, I was, like, out here and I was holding on.
-[ Laughs ] That's so good.
I gotta say "Barry" --
-I think I just pulled something.
-We just heard a sound effect. Yeah.
-Questlove, I want to just say that documentary was amazing!
-Yeah, it was great. -Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was great.
You do the show "Barry," and you win an Emmy for it.
And we all loved it. Oh, my gosh.
You know everyone loves you.
So -- But the acting was fantastic.
You were great, and Bill Hader was great.
But this season... -He's genius.
-...you took a -- you took it to a new level of acting.
-Well, first of all, if it ain't on the page,
it ain't on the stage. -Okay.
-So the writing -- Alec Berg and Bill and the --
And Liz and Duffy and all of the writers are amazing.
-And what you got to do with this character.
-Oh, my goodness.
And I want to say this Sunday is the final, right,
of the third season. -Yep.
-And I'm -- I'm willing to go so far to say there is a scene
that might be the most intense work
I have ever done
since the beginning of my career in 1970.
-Really? -Yes.
-And how is that -- -And Bill took me there.
And I worked with an actor that was just introduced last week,
Robert Wisdom, who plays the love of my life,
who Bill killed.
-Yes, that's right.
In the show. Yeah, of course.
-Stacey is backstage. -Of course. Yes. In "Barry."
-He plays her father.
-Oof. Buddy. -Yeah.
-Does Bill warn you when you do these scenes?
-No. He just --
You know, he just takes me to the place.
-Really? -He -- I'm not kidding.
Because at home, I rehearse the scene.
I think I've got it down.
And then I get to the set and I realize I was in Peru,
and he would like me in Bangladesh.
He takes me to a place I had never thought of.
-[ Laughs ] I love how you put it that way.
This is all gonna go in the memoir.
I can't wait to read this thing. I want to show everyone a clip.
-Do you want to write it?
-[ Laughs ] Yes, I do. Tariq!
Here is Henry Winkler in "Barry." Take a look at this.
-Ooh! -No, no, no. Don't laugh.
Keep it going, kids.
-Ooh-ooh!
-Now, how do you feel? -Like a ghost.
-Wrong. How do you feel?
-Embarrassed? -She's right.
Okay. Now do the scene.
-Doctor, the generators are down.
If we don't get electricity back in the park,
the dinosaurs will escape.
-Let's split up. -Stop.
Alright. Do you see the difference?
Huh? It is all in the body. It's much more real.
Now I believe she's got the code.
He's gonna ride the dinosaur. It's all gonna be fine.
You've got to embrace your embarrassment.
"I want a lollipop! I want it to be purple!"
Do I look like a fool? Not my problem.
-Now, that's how you do it!
That's how you do it! Henry Winkler!
Check out the season finale of "Barry"
this Sunday on HBO and HBO Max.
You smell great, by the way. You're a stud.